Yesterday,
Monday's lecture,
we were outlining the
expectations of the course
conceptually and practically.
Conceptually, remember
that I started with
Frederick Douglass' - an
excerpt from his great
speech, "What to the slave
is the Fourth of July?,
told the story about
how he had been honored,
in a sense, by his
abolitionist friends to
come to Rochester to
speak about the meaning of
independence,
Fourth of July,
how he refused to do so,
because to proceed in that
way for a man
who'd been a slave and
self-emancipated,
represented in so many
ways the enslaved
population of the United
States, that to invite him
to speak about liberty and
independence was "cruel
mockery." We also talked
about the ways in which,
going back from Frederick
Douglass's
speech in the 1850s,
going back to the 1770s
with the epitaph on the
tombstone, about the
ways in which freedom and
slavery intertwined,
if you're trying to
understand this
country's history,
and the way that
citizenship and
non-citizenship are
intertwined. I want to
pick up on some of
those same themes today,
and we are going to be
lingering for the most
part of this lecture just
prior to the start of the
Civil War.
I'll offer a few,
I mean, scant details
chronologically about the
Civil War, and end up with
the New York City draft
riots, happening in the
midst of the Civil War.
And so this lecture is
really our jumping off
point, from a
chronological perspective,
for this course.
And as you see,
by the end of the
lecture, some core themes,
again that I
articulated on Monday,
are going to be brought
back into focus by the end
of this narrative. So
I want to begin today's
lecture with a poem
by the journalist,
activist, Underground
Railroad host to those
slaves escaping towards
freedom (she would open
her doors to them),
woman's rights activist,
anti-lynching crusader,
woman by the name of
Frances Ellen Watkins
Harper. It's a poem
written in 1854, the
same moment that Frederick
Douglass is castigating
his abolitionist friends
about their
understandings of freedom,
and of liberty, and of
slavery. The poem is
called Bury Me in a Free
Land. And I want you to
listen. It's not--I'm not
going to say the poem is
high art. It's
better than I can do,
but it's not high art, I
don't think. But think
about the images that
are crafted in this
poem...sort of the
psychological terror
represented in this poem
as well. Bury Me in a Free
Land. "Make me a
grave where'er you will,
In a lowly plain,
or a loft hill;
Make it among
earth's humblest graves,
But not in a land where
men are slaves. I could
not rest if around my grave I
heard the steps of
a trembling slave; His
shadow above my silent tomb
would make it a place
of fearful gloom. I could
not rest if I heard the
tread of a coffle gang to
the shambles led, And the
mother's shriek of wild despair
Rise like a curse on the
trembling air.
I could not sleep if I saw
the lash. Drinking her
blood with each
fearful gash,
And I saw her babes
torn from her breast,
Like trembling doves from
their parent nest.
I'd shudder and start if
I heard the bay
Of bloodhounds seizing
their human prey,
And I heard the captive
plead in vain
As they bound afresh his galling
chain. If I saw young
girls from their mother's
arms, Bartered and sold for
their youthful charms, My
eye would flash with a
mournful flame, My
death-paled cheek grow
red with shame, I would sleep
dear friends, where bloated
might, Can rob no
man of his
dearest right;
My rest shall be calm in
any grave, Where none can
call his brother a
slave. I ask no monument,
proud and high, To
arrest the gaze of the
passers-by; All that my
yearning spirit craves,
Is bury me not in a
land of slaves." Again,
1854. Although the
literal start of the Civil
War is seven years away,
this was an era when it
was clear to people like
Frederick Douglass and
Frances Harper and so
many other individuals,
free and not free. This
is an era of incredible
tension in the
country, and really the
handwriting's on the wall
as the country's barreling
towards its sectional
crisis. As early as 1820,
the political battles had
begun with the Missouri
Compromise, an attempt
to balance the number of
slave states and free
states. The Missouri
Compromise angered the
South because of the way
the federal government
intervened in this
process. You're going to
hear this often in this
course. The tension
between federal government
initiatives and states'
rights initiatives. Who
has greater authority, the
federal government or the
states? Fundamentally
important to the post--or
to the African
American experience,
pre- and
post-emancipation. So in
1820 at the
Missouri Compromise,
balancing free
states and slave states,
so neither would have an
advantage in the federal
government when it came to
setting policy about labor
in particular. Fast forward,
1850, the
Compromise of 1850,
essentially the same
issues as in the Missouri
Compromise. It's relating
to territory gained in the
Mexican-American War. What part
of the United
States is going to be free
versus what part is going
to be--or what states are
going to allow slavery.
One of the most important
texts in US history,
novel, Uncle Tom's Cabin,
is published in 1852,
written by Harriet Beecher
Stowe. Quite a long time
before Oprah's Book Club,
the book sells in numbers
that are astonishing.
Three hundred thousand
copies of this text
are put into print,
and eventually, over a
million copies are sold.
This is in 1852.
It's--the numbers are sort
of incomparable to today.
The importance of the book
is that it galvanizes
through this sort of very
romantic and
treacley novel--it reads
very...it's an interesting
read in our contemporary
ears--but it galvanizes so
much of Northern opinion
about slavery
and, frankly,
helps pull this
country apart,
looking
backwards. In 1854,
you have the
Kansas-Nebraska Act,
that wipes out the
Missouri Compromise of
thirty-four years earlier
and starts a bloody war,
essentially a civil
war within Kansas about
whether we're
going to have slave
territories--slave states
or free states in these
areas. Out of the
battles in Kansas,
the Republican Party
emerges. It didn't exist
before. And it would
become the party that was
most sympathetic to
the African American
experience--African
Americans' interests in
becoming free and having
citizenship rights. It
becomes the party
with which blacks would
affiliate until
nineteen--the mid-1930s.
Now this takes us up
to around 1857. Again,
I'm fast-forwarding
through a lot of history
here, just to get to some
of the main themes of this
lecture. So the country
is being ripped apart
through a variety of
federal and state legal
battles about where people
can be free and where they
cannot, what states
can support slavery,
recognize it as being
legal. During all these
battles, a court case
is winding through the
system, a legal case, and
it's finally decided in
1857 by the Supreme
Court, Scott v. Sanders,
more famously, the Dred
Scott case. Now it's a
complicated case,
which I'll reduce to its
simplest forms. It's a
complicated case that
revolves around travel,
essentially. North of the
line thirty-six degrees
and thirty minutes related
to the Missouri Compromise
and the battles in Kansas
and Nebraska,
north of that line,
the country is--these are
free states. South of the
line, you're in
slave-holding
territories. Dred Scott
lives on both sides of
this line. He's a slave.
Sorry if I didn't make
that part clear. He's a
slave and lives with his
master and his mistress on
both sides of this line,
on and off over the course
of much of his life. And
for much of a decade, he's
living in free territory.
When his master
dies in 1846,
Scott sues for his freedom
on the ground that he had
been living in free
territory. "You can't own
me, I've been living
in a place that doesn't
recognize that status."
So he sues in court. The
courts go back and forth
until the Supreme Court
issues the final decision
in 1857. Eleven years
have transpired since the
original suit. And in the
course of these
cases--these decisions
going back and forth,
Dred Scott and his family,
if you can imagine,
have been emancipated,
re-enslaved,
emancipated, re-enslaved,
depending on the court's
decision. He's living a
life in a terrible--I mean
a limbo that we really
can't imagine. Well, the
Supreme Court weighs in
and solves the matter
once and for all. Chief
Justice Roger B. Taney
writes a decision that is
quite notable. He says
that Scott should remain a
slave, that by
virtue of his slavery,
he is not a citizen
of the United States,
and so could not bring
suit in a federal court in
the first place. He wipes
out the whole process.
"You were never a citizen,
because you were a slave.
You didn't have the
right to sue." Moreover,
Taney says,
that as a slave,
he was personal property,
and personal property can
never become free. We
think of personal property
as inanimate objects.
Certainly African American
slaves were not inanimate,
but for Taney it didn't
matter.
That's a gray area,
I mean if you could
call it a gray area,
that for Taney, that was a
gray area that was really
reduced to something
simple: They were personal
property; they could
not become free. Adding
insult to injury--I mean
the decision gets just
better and better from
the standpoint of raising
one's bile--Taney
makes plain his opinion of
blacks. "They
were," he offered,
and this is a quote, "so
far inferior that they had
no rights which a
white man was bound to
respect." "They were so
far inferior that they had
no rights which a
white man was bound to
respect." So
in one decision,
he eliminates
even the chance,
from a legal standpoint,
that you could sue if you
had been a slave. He
says that's not even a
possibility. Furthermore,
you're property and you
weren't free ever, and now
we shouldn't even respect
you anyway, because you're
so far inferior. Taney's
decision, building upon
the legislative battles of
the previous thirty-seven
years at that point,
building upon the tension
that's exacerbated,
I suppose, might
be the right word,
with Uncle Tom's Cabin.
Taney's decision helps
move the country closer
to Civil War because it
infuriates anti-slavery
advocates. On so many
levels of his decision, he
has made the wrong choice,
philosophically,
ethically and legally,
according to anti-slavery
advocates. The new
Republican Party which was
opposed to the expansion
of slavery--now notice,
it's the expansion,
not wiping it all out.
Things take time. The
Republican Party, which is
opposed to the expansion
of slavery, criticized
the decision. There's a
postscript to
this. In 1857,
we don't want to lose
sight of Dred Scott
himself.
Scott's mistress,
his master's
widowed--widow,
Dred Scott's mistress
remarries and gives Scott
and his family their
freedom. Now why she
couldn't do this eleven
years earlier is a mystery
that, you know,
only she could answer,
I suppose. But she gives
him and his family their
final freedom. And if you
remember the epitaph from
Monday, I mean
the painful,
bitter irony of
the whole process,
just like John Jack.
Not long after he buys his
freedom, he dies. One year
after Dred Scott finally
gets his freedom, an
eleven-year battle in the
legal system, one
year later he dies from
tuberculosis. It's a
bitter coda to a life of
struggle. So Dred
Scott dies in 1858.
Steadying--Continuing
this March,
1859, John Brown, former
principal of a seminary
where Frances Harper,
whose poem I read to you
earlier, the principal of
the seminary where Frances
Harper worked, becomes
an evangelizing zealot
against--or for
anti-slavery causes.
Slavery is
inhumane. It's unholy,
according to John Brown,
and he recognizes--or he
believes the way to
solve this problem,
since the legal
process isn't working,
since the process of moral
suasion isn't working,
is to get guns. John
Brown organizes a band of
armed abolitionists,
black and white men,
and their plan is to storm
the arsenal in Harpers
Ferry, Virginia. John
Brown invites Frederick
Douglass. "You're such
an important leader for
African Americans. You
need to join us in this
battle." And
Douglass says--I mean,
I wasn't there for
the conversation,
but--"John, you're
crazy." And he may have
been a bit, well,
visionary I suppose is
another word for crazy
in sometimes. He forms a
group, John Brown
does, and they begin their
raid. Doesn't last
very long. Robert E. Lee,
general in the
United States army,
not yet a traitor, quickly
defeats John Brown and his
associates. Brown is
wounded in the battle and
he's captured,
and in short order,
he's convicted of treason,
and he's ultimately
hanged. Between
the time of the raid,
or when he's
caught that is,
and his hanging, there's
a trial. And during that
trial, John Brown becomes
seen as a messianic hero
to many people.
Frances Harper,
again, has a note sent to
John Brown when he's in
prison that reads in part,
and I'm quoting from it
here, "In the name of the
young girl sold from the,
excuse me, In the name of
the young girl sold from
the warm--warm clasp of
a mother's arms to the
clutches of a
libertine or profligate,
in the name of
the slave mother,
her heart rocked to and
fro by the agony of her
mournful
separations, I thank you,
that you have been brave
enough to reach out your
hands to the crushed
and blighted of my race,
I thank you." Brown
himself fanned the flames
of celebrity during
the trial with long
soliloquies, all to no
avail. He's going to be
hung. Some of his last
famous--his famous last
words. He declares,
"I believe that to have
interfered as I have done
on behalf of this despised
poor, I did no wrong,
but right." To the end,
he was quite
certain his path,
armed resistance, was the
solution to a country that
could not figure
itself out on this issue,
whether it be a
slave holding country,
non-slave holding country
or some strange mix. John
Brown's raid in 1860,
Abraham Lincoln's elected
in 1860. Simplifying
a complicated story,
but essentially, the South
has no electoral presence
in the election, and it
felt that the Union was
doomed, and Southern
states begin to secede.
April of 1861, the Civil
War starts. Lincoln wants
to preserve the
Union at all costs,
and tries from the very
start to lure the South
back in with a plan of
compensated emancipation.
Essentially, "We'll pay
for your slaves. You
emancipate them, we give
you some money." Many
people in the North balk
at this idea. This is
crazy. And the South
completely refuses.
Lincoln tries to develop a
colonization plan to move
blacks to Latin America.
Now this is part of a
longer tradition. Lincoln
didn't just create an idea
of like solving the race
problem by getting rid of
the race. This has been
going back to this point
through
colonization societies,
thirty, forty,
fifty years,
and then in terms
of individual ideas,
much longer. But
Lincoln thinks,
"Well this is a solution.
We've got a problem with
slaves. Slaves were black
in this country." There's
also Native
American slaves,
but a much smaller
population. "We'll just
move them." That plan
doesn't work out either.
Now Lincoln has an
evolutionary viewpoint
when it comes to slavery,
in terms of its role in
society, pragmatically,
how it affected the Union,
the sustainability
of the Union,
or the possibility of
reconciliation of the
Union. He doesn't
support slavery,
but he could not find
a way to eliminate it,
and try to preserve or
reconcile the Union.
Political and pragmatic
pressures finally force
his hand. Congress had
already begun to chip away
at slavery by refusing to
allow captured slaves to
be returned to their
bonded status. And with
just a little over a
year after the Civil War
begins, Lincoln
essentially throws up his
hands. He goes, "There's
really no--there's no way
to solve this
problem," and decides that
emancipation is going to
be the solution. How are
we going to do it? What's
it going to look like? By
the end of the year, he's
drawn up the plans and
enunciated the policy
and on January 1st,
1863, the Emancipation
Proclamation takes
effect. Now the
proclamation is a
fascinating document.
It's compromised,
as most political things
are. It's a manifestation
of compromise and it
declares that the slave
population in any state
that's still in rebellion
against the United States
on January 1863--slave
populations in those
states that are in
rebellion against the
federal government,
against the United States,
at that moment would
become free. Now what
does this mean? It means,
curiously, not much in
a practical sense. If
you're in South Carolina,
you own slaves. Your
state had seceded from the
union. Lincoln says on
January 1863, "You
don't own those slaves
anymore." Well, if
you're in South Carolina,
you don't care what
Lincoln says. You still
own your slaves.
In Maryland though,
which sided
with the Union,
if I had a plantation that
owned slaves and I was in
Maryland, my state is not
in rebellion against the
U.S., I still own my
slaves. Now slavery in
Maryland is different from
slavery in South Carolina
on the level of type of
slavery and also scale of
it. So in terms of
literally freeing people,
the Emancipation
Proclamation doesn't. It
is still one of the most
important documents in the
history of the
United States,
because when you
think of politics,
there's the literal
effects and there's the
philosophical or cultural,
symbolic effects. You
think of the Emancipation
Proclamation in that way,
it is an astonishing
document. The Civil War,
the debates go on to
this day. The Civil War,
was it a war about
slavery? Was it a war
about just different
economic systems? Was it
a war about political
philosophy? And people
still argue themselves
blue in the face. But
what is clear is that
at the moment of the
Emancipation Proclamation,
the Civil War does become
about slavery. Even if
you were fighting it for
some other reason, the
stakes are very real,
that if the North
wins, if the Union wins,
slavery will be abolished
from the United States.
Now let's head towards
these last sort of twenty
minutes of the lecture.
We're going to stick north
for a while here. Now
the war is about slavery,
at least in this sort of
cultural politics of the
moment. It's a miserable
war. The South and the
North are beating
themselves up to a pulp
certainly, and Lincoln
faces a problem. The
Union troops face a
problem. They don't have
enough people. And as we
head through the winter of
1863, Lincoln decides he
has to try to find a way
to raise the number of
troops that are available
to fight in these
wars--in this war,
and you had the
Conscription Acts being
passed, and they're going
to take effect in March of
1863. And what the
Conscription Acts say is
that there's mandatory
military service for men
who are between age twenty
and forty-five unless--and
there always seems to be
an unless when it comes to
conscription--unless
they happen to have three
hundred dollars on them.
If you had three hundred
dollars, you could buy
yourself an exemption.
There's a long history
of that in this country,
and many other places.
The history is still with
us today. Political
leaders bought their
exemption. It's
called--you know it's
called, "Daddy's a
powerful political
figure. I will not go to
war." Conscription Acts
of March 1863 said if you
were between twenty and
forty-five, and
you were a man,
you had to serve, unless
you could find three
hundred dollars. Well,
three hundred dollars is a
huge sum of money, 1863,
so no surprise the wealthy
gave their money, and they
were exempt. Most of the
country wasn't wealthy.
This was a way to raise
troops and also raise
money. They needed both.
There was an unintended
effect. I don't think you
would have
been a surprise,
but it was an unintended
effect. It exacerbated
class tensions
within the country,
within the Union, I should
say. So as you're heading
into spring of 1863, the
battle is still going on.
Young men are dying
left and right. The war,
what is this war about
really? Who is it for?
It's about emancipating
these black slaves. And
you head into March and
you had these Conscription
Acts taking place. "Now
I have no choice but to
go." Then you head
into the summer and these
tensions, wondering
what the war is about,
not having the resources
to get out of risking
one's life, for something
you're not sure if you
even believe in. Class
tensions exacerbated. In
New York City, all of
these different tensions
combine and essentially
combust. What's going on
in New York in particular?
In addition to those
things I just
mentioned, in New York,
there are labor tensions.
Really dramatic labor
tensions. The Irish
immigrant population
treated horribly for quite
some time. The Irish
control the docks.
The Irish are already
struggling with local
blacks for that bottom
rung on the ladder. Who's
going to have a chance to
get a purchase on that
bottom rung and to start
to pull themselves up?
And the Irish dock workers
control this--these
important ports in New
York City.
Horrible, dirty,
messy, dangerous job,
but we're not going to let
blacks take this job. So
there's tensions in labor
ranks in terms of who can
actually be the laborer to
start to pull themselves
up by their bootstraps.
There is a fear adding
to this labor tension,
has an ethnic and racial
aspect to it--there's a
fear now that
since January of 1863,
since Lincoln
freed the slaves,
these slaves are going to
end up in New York City.
How they're going
to get there is,
you know, another issue,
but there's going to be a
fear--there's a fear of
a flood of emancipated
blacks coming up to New
York to find work. And
let's face it, these folks
had nothing. They'll take
any job, was the
expectation. And so the
Irish dock workers felt
even further antagonized
by the fact of job
insecurity and the fact
that this other,
these black folks,
were going to take
their jobs. Now as I said
before, the Irish, many of
them are brand new to this
country. They're
scrambling to secure their
own place as citizens in
this country. Looked down
upon, treated terribly by
other groups. And they
believed, aside from
wanting to keep these
jobs, that their claim to
citizenship rested in part
at least upon the fact
that they were not black.
This is a very important
point. It's not that it's
just about a job, but
about belonging. Irish
treated--like there'd
be signs in the stores,
"No Irish or dogs allowed
in." Blacks already
weren't allowed in. No
Irish or dogs. The Irish
were treated horribly,
and so they realized,
as long as they are
not like that person,
those
people--"that person,
"those people" being
black. Having been
emancipated, whether they
were actually ever a slave
or not, they are--they
are tarred in a sense with
that same label, from an
enslaved people--people
who weren't citizens in
many people's minds. The
Irish workers say, "Well,
at least I'm not that,
so I'm moving up the
ladder." So you take
emancipation, you take
the Conscription Acts,
which are certainly
affecting the Irish more
than any other population
in New York City,
you take the fear of
emancipated blacks coming
up and taking jobs
away from the Irish dock
workers, and it makes it
plain that the Irish now
feel incredibly
compromised. Everything
they had fought for might
be in danger of slipping
away. Their freedom, as
I mentioned when talking
about John Jack and
citizens of Concord in
1773, Irish workers'
freedom was incumbent upon
blacks' slavery. They're
intertwined. Now we're
into July of 1863, after
setting all this stage.
On July 11th, a first
lottery is held for
conscription. So
we've had this plan,
now we're going to make
it real. And within two
days, mayhem ensues. Now
New York is a port city.
So aside from having the
dock workers unloading
material goods
and products,
or loading them
onto these ships,
you have troops that
are being rallied from
different places in the
Northeast that are coming
down to New York City, or
they're leaving from New
York to head further south
into the military battles,
into military stages,
scenes. And so there's
all this tension around
the military being there.
And now, with the
Conscription Acts really
becoming--well
becoming real,
people are going to
be forced to don the
uniform. Several days
of rioting begin. The
military
command--commandant of the
region, anything
embodying military,
or suggesting
police control,
is targeted. So the
commandant is sought out.
Soldiers are sought out,
police are sought out.
They're targeted
by these gangs,
largely ethnic gangs,
largely Irish gangs.
They're the ones who felt
most at threat. And these
gangs also targeted
blacks. The call went out
from the commandant, "We
need more troops." Now it
takes a couple of
days, during 1863,
to get people
there. After a few days,
military troops are
brought in to the city to
restore calm. When
the dust has settled,
as many as a thousand
people are dead during
these riots. Anybody from
New York City? There's
got to be a couple of
people here. Well,
think of these
places: on the West Side,
Twenty-Seventh
and Seventh Avenue,
West Thirty-Third Street,
Thirty-Seventh and Seventh
Avenue. On the East Side,
Thirty-Fourth and East
River--a very
specific street--address,
One Hundred Forty-Seven
East Twenty-Eighth
Street. All of
these sites that you
have--you've
walked around them,
I know you have, these are
sites of lynchings in New
York City. We're not
talking about gangs
throwing rocks and beating
each other up. We are
talking about lynchings,
in addition to that as
well, I should
say. In total,
eleven people are lynched
during the several days of
riots. A few
examples: Joseph Reed,
separated from his
mother and grandmother,
he's beaten to death.
He's seven years old.
William
Williams, a sailor,
assaulted by
the longshoremen,
the dock workers, when
he asked for directions,
not knowing this riot is
happening. Someone picks
up a cobblestone, hurls
the stone at him. Someone
else stabs him.
The crowd cheers,
and they start
chanting--And I'm sorry to
use the language but
you'll be hearing it
several different
times in the course,
but this is just the
history of it all--start
chanting, "Don't hire
niggers! Don't hire
niggers!" Labor and
class all intertwined,
certainly citizenship
as well. The Colored
Orphanage, a very large
building there to take
care of
abandoned children,
the crowd sees this place
as a site of threat--I
guess you'd
say it's threat,
but something given to
blacks that the Irish
didn't have the benefit
of. And they decide
they're going to set
the orphanage on fire.
Thankfully, word gets to
the orphanage in time,
and they were able to
escape out the back as the
building is torched. So
the Colored Orphanage is
burned to the ground.
One story is particularly
illustrative, not a happy
story of course. On the
third day of riots,
Abraham Franklin,
a disabled black coachman,
and his sister Henrietta,
were pulled out of
their boarding room. Now
there's one thing I
forgot to mention that's
important, thinking about
this particular setting.
Blacks and Irish were sort
of--were at each others'
throats through
this process,
but they're living in
the same areas. They're
interacting all the time,
and that's what makes this
story that much more
horrific in a sense. Many
Irish--I don't want to
paint entire groups--many
Irish and blacks got
along perfectly fine,
and certainly commingled
in every way that you can
imagine that
word being used,
happily,
passionately, or angrily,
you name it. But they
were living in the--these
were their own
neighborhoods. Abraham
Franklin and his sister
Henrietta are pulled out
of their boarding room.
Henrietta is beaten while
Abraham is
hanged. Federal troops,
who are now coming into
the city trying to quell
the riot as it moves
to different places,
federal troops arrive, and
they cut down his body.
It's too late to save his
life. Troops break up the
crowd and then disperse,
heading off to another
flashpoint. The rioting
crowd re-hangs the body,
and they start chanting.
Just as you had William
Williams being murdered
to chants of "Don't hire
niggers,"
inflammatory declaration,
in Abraham
Franklin's case,
you have chants
coming out from the crowd,
inflammatory in a
different way. They
re-hang his body to chants
of "Jeff Davis! Jeff
Davis" What does this
mean? They're praising
the president of
the Confederacy,
Jefferson Davis. So
you have Irish workers,
living with other African
Americans certainly,
feeling threatened that
their citizenship is at
stake, deciding to take
our their threat--and
feeling they might be
conscripted into the
military, likely would
be--they decide to take
out their anxiety, fears,
and anger on the Colored
Orphanage, on
seven year old boys,
on sailors, on disabled
black coachmen. And
they're going to honor the
idea of keeping people out
of unions. "Don't hire
niggers." And they're
going to honor, curiously,
the presidency of the
Confederacy--president
of the Confederacy. So
Abraham Franklin is
hung, body cut down. He's
re-hung--re-hanged, excuse
me--and then later on,
after the crowd disperses
to do something else,
somewhere else, a
sixteen-year old Irish
butcher cuts down
Franklin. Maybe his body
will finally be
put to rest. No,
in fact the butcher
decides to drag his body
through the
streets as a trophy,
in so doing, I claim,
marking his own claim to
citizenship on the dead
body of a black--of a
crippled black man. Now
what's the point of all
this narrative? The point
of this is that we can see
in the crucible of the
Civil War a very clear
picture of what it means
to be a citizen and what
it means to be American.
A foundational question
for this class, as I
mentioned in Monday's
lecture. Douglass
questioned the sanctity of
July Fourth, that
great cultural marker of
freedom. "Why would
you bring me here,
representing a people
who only know slavery?"
Harper, the poet
and journalist,
activist, makes clear how
blind people were to the
psychological
anguish of slavery,
children being torn from
their mothers' breasts.
The Dred Scott case is
explicitly about who could
be a citizen of the United
States. Taney didn't
think any slave could be
a citizen. They're too
inferior and they're
property. The political
turns made out
of necessity,
and this is
very important,
made out of necessity
in the Civil War,
made it absolutely plain
to people like Abraham
Lincoln, who starts to
decide to change these
policies; made it
absolutely plain that
citizenship was going
to be linked to freedom,
and that freedom was
linked to race. The
connection is certainly
there in terms of social,
cultural forums.
It's there in political
forums. It is tangible.
As soon as he signs into
being the
Emancipation Proclamation,
and in the fallout through
the Conscription Acts and
the New York
City draft riots,
it is real. Citizenship
is linked to freedom;
freedom is linked to
race. The tensions
between all of these
linkages are made really
quite perfectly clear
by those people who are
rioting in New
York City. And,
I really think, made
abundantly clear when
Abraham Franklin was
dragged through the
streets of New York by his
genitals. Thank you very
much. I'll see
you on Friday.